foreign
welcome to this data analyst full course
video by simply learn
in this full course you will learn all
about how to become a data analyst this
video will help you get acquainted with
the duties and career prospects of a
data analyst along with various data
analytics Concepts
here we will start by understanding the
career of a data analyst and what a data
analysts Duties are
then we will list the top 10 data
analyst skills and the top 10 data
analysis tools
moving on we will distinguish a data
analyst from a data scientist and we
will also pit the role of a data analyst
against a few of the roles like business
analysts and data engineer
we will then move on to learning data
analytics with python
following which we will learn a few
Excel Concepts that can help you in your
role as a data analyst
foreign
we will also look into pandas and
matplotlib
next we will understand data analytics
using r
not to forget we are also going to learn
about SQL
finally we will conclude this full
course by understanding the top data
analyst interview questions that you
could be asked in your next interview
a team of experts will take you through
the various topics in this full course
you can learn all of these topics in
Under 12 hours
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn
in a world where there is data
generation every millisecond the role of
a data analyst holds Paramount
importance this video will help you
understand what a data analyst does and
the various skills required to back this
position
before understanding the job role of a
data analyst let's understand the
meaning of the term data analytics
so what does the term analyze mean it
merely means to scrutinize something to
derive meaningful conclusions from it
well data analytics also works similarly
it is the process by which useful
insights are extracted from raw data by
studying and examining it carefully
these insights can be related to
business information market trends
product Innovations and profit loss
report to name a few
here's an interesting comparison I'm
sure all of you have played with jigsaw
puzzles at some point in time for that
first you would have to gather all the
pieces together and then fit them
accordingly to bring out a beautiful
picture isn't it we can simply relate
the process of data analytics to how you
make a jigsaw puzzle
as you can see here data refers to the
raw data which can be structured
semi-structured or unstructured in
nature the process of data analytics
incorporates collecting data from
various sources cleaning it and then
finally transforming it into something
meaningful which can be interpreted by
humans
this information can be visually
presented in the form of graphs and
charts which provide precise results of
the analysis
various Technologies tools and
Frameworks are used in the analysis
process organizations take the help of
data analytics to convert the available
raw data into meaningful insights hence
there is a high requirement for
professionals who can play with data and
help organizations with crucial decision
making
there are many job roles in the field of
data analytics if you have watched our
previous video on data analytics Courier
you would have seen a few of these roles
out of all the job roles an important
role is that of a data analyst an
interesting thing about this job role is
that it can be taken up by freshers as
well it can embark on your career in the
field of data analytics it is a
lucrative career as the field of data
analytics is only going to continue to
Blossom in the years to come
so let's see who exactly a data analyst
is
a data analyst is a person who collects
processes and performs analysis on large
data sets here the statistical analysis
is done on various data sets every
business generates and collects data be
it marketing research sales figures
customer feedback Logistics or
Transportation costs a data analyst will
take all of this data and figure out
various measures such as how to price
new materials how to reduce
Transportation costs how to provide
better customer experience or how to
deal with issues that cost the company
money
data analysts also deal with data
handling data modeling and data
reporting
a data analyst has a number of Duties to
perform let's have a look at their
responsibilities now
first and foremost a data analyst is
required to recognize and understand the
organization's goal this helps in
streamlining and planning the analysis
process accordingly data analysts assess
the available resources understand the
business problem and gather the right
data this step is done by collaborating
with different team members such as
programmers business analysts and data
scientists
data analysts need to use queries to
gather information from a database they
write complex SQL queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
they are responsible for data mining as
well here data is mined from various
sources and then organized in order to
obtain a new information from it this is
a vital role of a data analyst as they
have to extract data from various
sources in order to work on it with this
data they can build models it can reduce
a complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system
another crucial step in data analysis is
data cleaning and data wrangling usually
the data you can collect is often messy
and has a lot of missing values so it's
important to clean this data to make it
ready for analysis
data analysts use a number of
statistical and analytical tools
including programming languages for
performing analysis and logical
examination of data
using different libraries and packages
data analysts discover Trends and
patterns from complex data sets this
will help them find more unseen insights
from the data to make business
predictions
another important role of a data analyst
is to prepare summary reports for the
leadership team so that they can make
timely decisions for this data analysts
use multiple data visualization tools
some of these tools are discussed as
part of skills required which we will
see later
finally data analysts interact with the
development team business and management
team as well as with data scientists to
ensure proper implementation of business
requirements and to figure out
opportunities for better process
Improvement
now let us look at the various skills
required to become a data analyst
so the first skill is more of a
prerequisite you should hold a degree in
any relevant field be it engineering
computer science Information Technology
electrical and mechanical engineering
you can also be a graduate in statistics
or economics also you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are currently
working in or the role you're applying
for
the next important skill is that you
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages such as R
Python and JavaScript this would help
you write programs to solve complex
problems
then you should have a good experience
working with databases and data analysis
tools such as writing SQL queries and
procedures knowledge of Microsoft Excel
IBM SPSS and Matlab to analyze Trends
forecast data and plan to drive accurate
insights